在大多数交易者心中
爆仓是一个可以避免的结果
只要策略成熟
止损到位
心态稳定
就有机会长久生存
但如果你把这些表面因素抽离
回到交易系统本身
会发现一个更冷静事实
爆仓并不是偶然的失败
而是由概率分布和资金规划共同决定的结果
这个结局并不因为你不够聪明
而是你所参与的游戏本身
早就设定好了出局概率
而你没有察觉
我们从最基础的假设推起
设想一个最公平的系统
胜率50%
盈亏比一比一
每次交易不是盈利
就是亏损幅度相等
这种设定听起来像是理性系统的理想形态
然而这恰恰是陷阱的起点
在这个系统中
只要你交易的足够多
就必然会遇到某些阶段性的极端情况
比如连续三次亏损
根据这个最基本的概率来计算
这意味着在完全对称的胜负条件下
每进行八次交易
就大概率会遇到一次三连亏
而在这次交易中
大多数人每周每月都可能进行几十轮操作
也就是说你不仅会遇到三连亏
而且会反复遇到一年交易50轮
理论上你将遇到六次以上的三连亏
几乎没有逃避空间
连亏不是万一
而是迟早更关键的是
大多数散户的账户设计资金安排和心理弹性
并没有为他预留任何空间
而一旦连亏发生
真正威胁你的其实不是当下那商品亏损本身
而是它会在资金曲线上形成
一次极难弥补的损套段
这个缺口会让你彻底看清
你所谓的风控其实只是纸上的模型
一旦三连会发生对账户的打击
并不是亏了30%这么简单
我们来做个简单演算
假设每次交易亏损10%
连续三次后
账户所剩比例为73%
只是你距离回本还差多少
不是27%
而是37%回撤曲线是指数下降
而恢复则是线性增长
越早亏损或许回本所需涨幅越陡
如果再遇到一次类似的三连亏
本金将倍达到50%左右
市场给予一次反向波动
你的交易计划就彻底失败
CN也将进入不可逆的崩盘区间
这还是在未使用杠杆为重仓
未补单的理想条件下计算
现实中
大多数交易者在面临亏损时的反应
并不是按计划止损
而是试图翻身
而你的资金很可能没等到这类发挥的时间窗口
所以风险并不是亏了多少
而是你亏完之后还会做出什么
接下来要说的就是散户面对连亏时
最真实也最致命的反应链条
市场的波动只是起点
真正导致账户爆炸的是人类本能
对亏损的拒绝承认
当你经历一轮连续亏损
召回撤超过预期
理性的边界开始崩解
你开始做一些不会做的决定
加上补亏
取消止损所
但频繁出手
放弃原有策略
这些行为的底层动因并不是市场在变
而是你在试图抵抗亏损
而不是处理亏损
你想要的是扳回来
市场给你的则是再下一刀
许多散户并不是死在那一次突然的爆仓
而是死在无数次我还能做一次的累积中
情绪与资金的双重叠加
使得爆仓这个结果看似突然
其实早已写入每一次错误反应之后的路径中
也就是说你不是被市场打爆的
而是自己把自己逼到无法生还的位置
从这里开始
我们要把注意力从事件转向系统
因为决定你能不能活下来的
不是单次操作的好坏
而是整个账户的抗风险模型是否能穿越周期
很多交易者误以为只要自己的判断够准
胜率超过50%
账户就一定能增长
但这恰恰是一个对市场节奏的误读
市场不会平均的给你一次赚一次赔
他不会照顾你的节奏感
也不会按系统均值来摆输赢数据
你可能连赢
也可能连输
而大多数账户并没有准备好CTRL或连续的坏结果
你以为自己在参与一场赢一半输一半的博弈
其实更像在赌场里连续压住同一方向的百家乐
只要输了三把
你的筹码就打穿了止损线
而一旦你开始加注
下一轮输的只会更快
真正的问题不是能不能对一次
而是能不能撑过那几次错
要做到这一点
你需要两侧稳定性
一是账户的抗压能力
20年在亏损时的操作一致性
而多数散户在实际交易中很难同时维持这两点
一遇连亏就乱
越乱越亏
最后连规则都守不住
他们指望市场
别看好
在我最脆弱的时候出招
但真正情况是你脆弱的那一刻
往往就是他出招的时机
所以真正决定生死的不是你赢多少
而是你能不能从最差的一次中活着出来
爆仓的本质从来不是市场太坏
也不是策略太差
它只是一个结果
是你在数学期望的随机波动中
没有构建起任何防线
最终被概率兑现的死亡通知
你控制不了运气
无法决定什么时候你会不会来
但你能决定当那雷临时
你是否还能活着
真正的生存系统设计的不是永远赚钱
而是即使最坏的情况发生
我还能继续交易
爆伤不可怕
可怕的是你从未意识到他不是命运
而是系统中的一个节点
你早该为他留好位置
而不是在他出现时崩溃失控
爆伤不是突发事件
而是每一次你拒绝认错
死扛到底的加总
这不是你赌输了
而是你从没意识到这场游戏不该由你来玩